All right, yes guys, welcome back to
another video and today I'm going to be
showing you a couple examples of the
easiest model that you need to become
profitable in 2026. Now, this is a model
that I've been using ever since I
started trading in 2023, through 2024,
and 2025. Um
I'm going to show you guys how effective
this model can be just in a couple
minutes of looking for a trade in these
particular sessions. So, what we have
here is the macros that I actually
trade. So, we have the first day macro,
which is 9:45 to 10:15 New York local
time. And as it says here, if there's no
setup inside of the first macro, we
shall wait for the 10:45 and 11:15
macro. And if we don't find anything
there, then we have also the 11:45 and
12:15 lunch macro. Now, also, it doesn't
matter even if we do take a win in any
of these macros, we will continue to
trade every single macro unless we take
two losing trades before the last
session, which would be the only time
that we stop trading for the day. So,
basically, you could take a win every
macro. Doesn't matter. There's no real
it doesn't make sense to stop trading
after one win when
every single trade has its own
probability. And it doesn't matter just
because it's a different day. If price
is moving algorithmically that day, then
you should expect more winning trades to
come about. So, then after lunch macro,
we then
we don't trade the end of lunch, which
would be 12:45 to 1:15.
So, that's a low probability macro. We
would then skip an hour and 30 minutes
towards the PM macro, which is 1:45 to
2:15.
And that's the last macro that we trade,
and that's going to be the first example
of a trade I'm going to show you guys
today. So,
which session actually has the highest
probability? And that would be the first
day macro, and that's because it's 15
minutes after the New York open, which
is when the stock exchange actually
opens up. So, it injects high liquidity
and therefore makes it high probability.
As it is the start of the New York
session. And other macros we also have
is the London macro. I was previously
trading the London macro for quite a
while, but recently it hasn't been the
greatest price action, so I've taken a
bit of a break from the London macro.
Although, you know, over the course of a
year, it is a profitable macro. Now,
uh another conversation for another time
would be is it actually worth uh your
time coming every day to the markets and
actually trading this macro just for
potentially 1 to 2 R or more each month?
I don't know. That's another topic of
discussion. But yeah, that is the London
macro. If you were to trade it, there's
3 to 4 a.m. Or you could trade uh 2:45
to 3:15, and then you'd have 3:45 to
4:15. So, yeah, you could have traded
the hour or the macro, you know, they're
both very high probability. So,
there you have it. And if there is a
good setup outside of macro, even by 5
minutes, should you take it? No, you
shouldn't. And here's why. Because
the macros are there for a reason,
right? Inside of that 30-minute window,
that is the highest probability that
price is actually going to play out in
your favor.
And what this actually does, it creates
discipline for where you're not looking
at the charts all day and you're only
looking at specific points for where you
want the model to present. And this will
actually increase your probability as
you're taking a high frequency amount of
trades inside of these windows. If
you're trading the full session, you can
it can become a bit crazy, just, you
know, getting absolutely demolished
because you don't actually know what
you're looking for. And sometimes you
just caught get caught up in very bad uh
market conditions when actually it's
just waiting for that next macro session
where it's building structure or
manipulating to a key level to then,
after that, build structure and actually
present the distribution phase
uh inside of the macro, which is what
you will happen
which is what you'll find actually
happen uh more times than not. So, yeah.
Even if it's 1 minute outside, you
should not take that trade. It's outside
of your rules, and you need to create
discipline for yourself, otherwise it's
going to lead to bad habits in the long
run. So, without further ado, let's
[snorts] get straight into the
breakdown. All right, yes guys, so we're
on the charts and we're about to
approach the PM session. So, the PM
session would be at this time. I
personally have my timings on London as
that's just what I'm used to, but, you
know, you can
uh re-equate this to New York, uh which
is 1:45. So, first thing we're going to
do is mark out our key points of
liquidity. So, on both NQ and ES,
Okay, perfect. So, we can see here on
both NQ and ES, we've actually swept
we've actually swept sell-side
liquidity.
And with the sweep of sell-side, that
would be the first step. So, now we're
sweeping sell-side, you want to match it
with a bullish bias, and you'd use the
bias dictated by imbalances. Straight
imbalances, no PD arrays, no order
blocks on the high time frame, straight
imbalances. Okay? So, we take a look at
the 4-hour, we can see that we
previously inversed these 4-hour bullish
gaps to the left, which then took the
4-hour swing high. It then traded into a
bearish gap, so that would have made the
4-hour bearish. Again, coming down, it's
traded into a bearish gap, making it
bearish. Takes out the swing low, that
makes the 4-hour neutral. Now, from this
point onwards, we can actually see price
has not traded into any other bearish
gaps. So, the 4-hour would remain as
neutral and not bullish. We haven't
traded into any bullish imbalances to
the left.
So, this is okay. I mean, we can also
see here it's inversed a bullish gap to
the left, too. But then it goes to then
take out this 4-hour swing low, which is
the next objective. So, that would be
the 4-hour's neutral.
Okay, so if we take a look at the
1-hour, we can see that the 1-hour is
trading out of
a bearish gap. So, the 1-hour would be
bearish or trading into a bullish gap to
the left. No, we're not. We've got a
bullish gap resting at 654. So, that has
not reached that point as of yet. So,
the 4-hour the 1-hour is actually
bearish. You can see it traded into it
here, but then it traded into a bearish
gap more recently. So, the 1-hour is
bearish.
So, if we now take a look at the 15, we
can see we're clearly trading into a
15-minute bullish gap. So, that would
put the 15 as bullish. And then we take
a look at the five, the five is also
trading into two bullish gaps. So, we
have the five and 15 as bullish, 1-hour
bearish, 4-hour neutral. So, let's take
a look at the daily time frame. If we
look at the daily time frame, we have
this small daily bullish gap just to the
left. We open this up a bit more, you
can see it more clearer. This is the
daily bullish gap that price is trading
out of. So, therefore, you would have a
daily
bullish bias.
So, overall, we have a bullish bias,
which is the second step. We have a
sweep of sell-side with a bullish bias.
So, now we would simply look for a shift
in market structure above this swing
high, which would be inversing this
bearish order block, and we'd want to
see it be paired with a gap so we can
take a long towards these points of
buy-side. So, let's see what we get.
Okay, so we can see right here that
price takes out the most recent
short-term low on ES,
and it doesn't take it on NQ. So, this
would be a lower time frame bullish SMT
at the lows.
An SMT isn't exactly
uh compulsory when taking trades, but it
is a good additional confluence to look
out for
when taking these trades. So, right here
now we can see we're getting a shift in
market structure above this swing high,
and then we're also getting it on ES.
So, if we were to form a gap, which we
are on ES as of right now, and we just
need to form one on NQ, then that would
be
textbook for longs.
So, there we go. Price puts in a gap on
both NQ and ES. So, once NQ forms that
gap, a tap on ES on this gap would
validate for longs. So, I would look for
longs off this gap on NQ.
I'd run my stop at the most recent
short-term low, and then we can look for
a 1 to 3 RR. All right, there we go. So,
we can see right there,
ES has tapped back into this bullish
fair value gap. So, we can see it right
here, ES taps the gap.
So, you would have a premature entry on
NQ.
There we go.
So, you would enter in for longs,
readjust your position, so you'd now be
running a 27-point stop. So, you'd run
your stops just at the most recent
short-term low,
and then
we could still target these highs for a
1 to 2 RR, or you could target
this drawing liquidity for a 1 to 3
still if you're looking for that 1 to 3
RR. Usually, a 1 to 2 or 1 to 3 is
perfect. You wouldn't really want to
look for anything more than that.
So, premature entry on NQ after ES taps
the gap. So, let's see how this trade
presents.
Okay, so off rip, we can already see
that price takes the first short-term
high. You would
trail to the most recent short-term low,
which would be this point here, taking
off the majority of risk.
And then you can also see that price
takes out a short-term high 50% of the
range between your entry and your take
profit. So, this would be your
break-even point. And we can see quite
clearly NQ has taken this point. So,
right here you would go risk-free on
this trade.
And then keeping an eye on NQ,
and keeping an eye on ES, this is final
objective, so if we were to take out
this high, then we would be all out of
this position, closing up prematurely.
There we have it, guys. So, that is TP
smashed, a full 1:3 RR. You can actually
go back to the 5th of February and see
me take this trade live.
Uh it was taken live inside of the
Discord, too. Every single trade that
I'll show you guys will be taken as a
live execution. So, nothing is gone back
and cherry-picked. It's quite clearly
things I've taken real time in the
markets, so I can back up what I'm
actually teaching you guys here. So,
this is such an easy, simple model for
you guys to learn and with consistency
and straight execution without
second-guessing or, you know, having
having uncertainties on if it's the
correct trade or not, will this play out
or not. If the model presents, guys, and
it's clean, it's in your favor, it's
what you look for, then that's a trade
you have to take. You can't not take the
trade because that's going to mess up
probabilities, and if you miss wins and
you miss losses, you know, these are
things that dictate your probability and
your edge over the course of the year.
So,
last one, guys. So, I hope you have
enjoyed this video. If you did find
information from it, make sure to drop a
sub and like on the video if you did
enjoy. And if you look in the
description of this video, you can join
up the free Discord where I'm giving
free weekly intel and value, where we do
weekly calls and I'll go live once every
2 weeks for you guys. Potentially, I'm
still thinking about how I'll do that,
but definitely free weekly calls every
week where you'll be able to
ask me questions and
where you'll be able to ask me any
questions you may have about, you know,
the strategy or trading in general. So,
I hope you guys have enjoyed and I'll
catch you in the next one. Peace.